- [Voiceover] In the video on
the auto-ionization of water
we saw that you could have
two neutral water molecules,
but one of them could swipe
a hydrogen ion from the other
and then you could be
left with a hydronium ion,
and the one that had the
hydrogen ion swiped from it,
remember a hydrogen ion
is really just a proton.
This one actually gains an electron,
it gains an electron from that hydrogen.
It takes all the electrons
from this covalent bond,
right over here, and it
forms another lone pair
and it gets a negative charge,
and that becomes a hydroxide ion.
Or we could also describe that
auto-ionization like this,
that if I have one water molecule,
well the oxygen grabs
both of the electrons
from this lone pair,
swipes hydrogen of the
one electron it had,
and all it's left with is its protons.
Well, hydrogen ion, it's really
just talking about a proton
because the most common
isotope of hydrogen
only has a proton in it's nucleus,
it does not have a neutron.
So you take away its electron,
you just have that proton left.
And the whole point of doing this to show,
well look, its not going
to be a typical thing,
most of the water molecules
aren't going to be doing this,
but this is going to happen
if you have a large enough
quantity of water molecules.
And we've even seen to
what degree that happens,
how typical that is by
looking at the concentration.
If we looked at the concentration,
so if we're talking about pure water,
we've seen that the concentration,
and we can think about it in two ways.
If we think about this top way
of expressing the auto-ionization,
we can say the concentration
of hydronium ions,
or if we think about this one over here,
we could think about the
concentration of hydrogen ions.
And the reason why these
two things are equivalent,
is because these hydrogen ions
are really just going
to associate themselves
with the water molecule
and become hydronium.
But in pure water, at 25 degrees Celsius,
we've seen that these are
going to be approximately
the concentration, whether you think of it
as hydronium concentration or
hydrogen ion concentration,
it's going to be
approximately one times ten
to the negative seven molar.
What does that mean?
Well molar, this is just
the units for molarity,
that's the same thing as one times ten
to the negative seven
moles, moles per liter.
If you have trouble
remembering what moles are,
first of all I encourage
you to watch that video
on Kahn Academy on moles.
But, we just have to remind
ourselves it's a quanity.
Just as a dozen means twelve of something,
a mole of something means 6.022 times,
and roughly 6.022 times 10
to the 23rd of that thing.
So it's just a very,
very, very large quanity.
So that's the concentration,
that you could say
the hydrogen ion concentration
in pure water at 25 degrees Celsius.
But, we could ask ourselves
that same question
for other types of solutions.
For example, orange juice.
So let's just say right over here,
so in orange juice,
the hydrogen ion concentration,
and once again I could also say
this is a hydronium concentration.
Depending on your glass of orange juice,
it wouldn't be atypical to find a glass
that has a hydrogen ion concentration
of say one times ten to
the negative 3.5 molar.
So once again, this is
actually a lot more then this,
actually let me make it a round number,
you actually might be
able to find something
at one times ten to the
negative four molar.
I looked it up on the internet,
there's actually a range
kind of in the mid threes
to low fours of hydrogen ion
concentration for orange juice.
So you could find something like this,
and as you can tell, it's
good to always just think
about the numbers, this is actually
a much higher concentration
than this over here.
The exponent over here is less negative,
so this is a higher concentration,
so this is a higher concentration.
We could look at something
that has a lower concentration.
Say something like bleach.
So bleach, I'll write
that right over here,
I actually looked it up
on the Clorox website.
The Clorox bleach,
they say that their
hydrogen ion concentration
is approximately - so their
hydrogen ion concentration -
is approximately equal to one times ten
to the negative twelve molar.
So this is a much lower concentration
than you would have in
just water right over here,
in pure water at 25 degrees Celsius.
So this is a much lower concentration,
this exponent over here is more negative.
This is a lower concentration.
Well this is all well and good,
but it can get a little bulky
talking about concentrations
in terms of the scientific notation,
something times something to
the negative whatever molar.
So to help simplify that,
people have invented the idea of a pH.
Let me introduce it in a color
that I have not used yet before.
You use lowercase p, uppercase h.
I've looked into where
this notation comes from,
the h most people agree is
referring to the hydrogen
in some way, but the p some people think
is referring to potential,
some people just think
it's a random letter
that was associated in
with one of these historical artifacts.
But, this is defined
as the negative log of,
and we could say negative
log, if we don't write a base,
you assume it's base 10.
But, the negative log of the
hydrogen ion concentration,
or it's equivalently the negative log,
because the hydrogen ions are
really hydronium ions, H3O.
It's really the same
thing as this as well.
So given this definition of pH,
let's calculate the pH's for pure water
at 25 degrees Celsius,
the pH of this glass of orange juice,
or the pH of this bleach.
Well, the pH of this pure
water is going to be,
so the pH here, so I have
some space right over here,
it's going to be the negative log,
and I'll write the base 10
there just cause that's assumed,
of its hydrogen ion concentration,
which is one times ten to
the negative seven molar.
We want molarity right over here,
you want molarity right over here.
Well, one times ten to the negative seven
is the same thing as
ten to the negative 7,
and if you look at just the
part where the log here,
before we think about the negative.
This is just saying to what
power do we have to raise ten,
to get ten to the negative seven power?
Well, that's just going
to be negative seven.
If what I just did is confusing,
I encourage you to review
logarithms on Khan Academy.
So we're going to have the
negative of negative seven,
which is going to be
equal to positive seven.
So the pH of pure water
at 25 degrees Celsius,
and temperature would matter
because it might affect auto-ionization.
The pH at 25 degrees celsius is seven.
What about this orange juice?
Well the pH over here is going
to be the negative log of -
Instead of writing one times
ten to the negative four,
I can just write ten to the negative four,
and of course that's a base 10.
Well, what do I have to raise ten to,
to get ten to the negative four,
well I'll have to raise that
to the negative four power.
The negative of negative
four is positive four.
By that same argument, or by
applying the same definition,
the pH of this bleach is going to be equal
to the negative log of ten
to the negative twelve.
I'm just ignoring this
one times right over here,
I could write one times
ten to the negative twelve,
but that's not going to change its value.
That of course is going to
be equal to the negative
of negative twelve,
which is positive twelve.
So it might be fun to plot all of these.
Let me do that.
So let me plot these pH's.
So we draw a line right over here,
and let's say that this is
zero, one, two, three, four -
which I'm not gonna be able
to all the way to twelve,
so I'll have to make my
scale a little bit smaller.
Zero, one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, eleven, twelve, and I
could keep going over here.
So let me write this, one,
two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve.
So these are our pH's over
here, I could plot em.
That water at 25 degrees Celsius
is gonna be right over
here, and that is my water.
That's sometimes referred
to as a neutral pH.
If I look at that orange
juice with a pH of four,
that orange juice is
gonna be right over here,
and I've seen ranges for orange juice,
that's actually more in
this range right over here,
so depending on your glass, or
whether it's gone bad or not,
so that's going to be orange juice,
could be found in that range.
So I'll write orange juice, orange juice.
And then this bleach,
and it depends on the
concentration and all of that,
but this bleach in particular
is right over here,
this bleach is right over here.
I could plot other things, your stomach,
the juices in your stomach,
are highly, highly -
well I'll talk about the
acidic a little bit more -
but your stomach juices are going to be -
let me do this in a new color -
are going to be in this
range right over here.
So stomach acid, and often
instead of stomach juices,
stomach acid.
If you had something like seawater,
it's going to be in this range,
right over here, seawater.
Now let's think about
what this is telling us,
and remember this is a logarithmic scale,
as we go to the right, our
concentration is going down,
it's important to recognize,
and that's all because of
this negative right over here,
in our definition.
But we saw that bleach has
a much lower concentration
than the water has.
So this is lower hydrogen
ion concentration.
As we go to the left we have
a higher hydrogen ion concentration.
Higher hydrogen ion concentration.
In general, if something
has a pH below seven,
we tend to refer to it as acidic.
We say it is acidic.
So typically when you add
acids to neutral water,
your pH is going to go down,
it's going to get more and more acidic.
As you go to the right, if
you have a pH above seven,
sometimes you'll hear people say basic
and sometimes you also might
hear people say alkaline.
It is becoming more alkaline,
it's hydrogen concentration
is getting lower,
and lower, and lower as
we move to the right.
I really want you to appreciate
the logarithmic nature of it
because if I handed you some seawater
with a pH of eight, you
might say okay no big deal
pH of eight relative to a pH of seven,
but this is a logarithmic scale,
if we're moving to the right,
we have a ten times lower
concentration of hydrogen ions.
If we were to move three
spaces to the right on this,
where it's one-tenth,
one-tenth, one-tenth,
we have one-thousandth the
concentration of hydrogen ions.
It's pretty interesting to think about
how much lower the hydrogen
concentration is in say bleach
than in water, and how much lower that is
than say stomach acid or orange juice.